آه، تمام.
الـ quantum circuit هو وحدة القيمة
في مشروعك، والـ qubit هو وحدة المعلومة،
لكن الـ circuit هو وحدة الحساب.
خلونا نفهم إيش هو الـ quantum circuit
ونشوف تركيبته.
هذا شكل الـ quantum circuit،
يتكون من أجزاء — الـ qubits
ممثَّلة بالخطوط الأفقية، وهنا عندنا
circuit فيه أربع qubits زي ما تشوف
هنا. أما الـ gates فهي
الطريقة اللي نتحكم فيها بالـ qubits،
وتقراها من اليسار لليمين.
الـ gates اللي تشتغل على qubit واحد ممكن تكون
single-qubit gates أو multi-qubit gates.
شايف هناك الـ controlled gate؟
هو اللي فيه خط بين اثنين من الـ qubits،
وهناك بتصير عملية التشابك الكمي.
وأخيراً عندك القياس والمخرجات الكلاسيكية.
ومهم جداً تعرف إنك بتشغّل الـ circuit مرات كثيرة
عشان تحصل على النتيجة، وهذا اسمه shots.
فعداد الـ shots هو عدد المرات
اللي لازم تكرر فيها الحساب عشان توصل للنتيجة.
طيب،
كيف تبدو؟
خلونا نشوف كيف يبدو الـ two-qubit
اللي كانت في الصورة قبل، اللي فيها تغيير الطور،
وأريتكم عملية كيف نسوي دوران يحقق
عملية التداخل هذي.
خلونا نقارن بين الـ classical circuit
والـ quantum circuit — في الـ classical circuit
ما راح تشوف ألوان زرقاء أو شيء من هذا،
ما في دورانات، كل شيء وردي بسيط،
وتحصل على حالات منفصلة واضحة.
وهذه الـ gates اللي نشوفها في الـ classical
لكن لاحظ الفرق الكبير اللي بيظهر
لما نطبق quantum circuit فعلي.
هذي هي الـ circuits الحقيقية اللي نشغّلها على حواسيبنا الكمية،
وتقدر تجربها أنت كمان.
الـ circuits اللي بنبنيها
بتركيب الـ gates مع بعض
تولّد الصورة الكاملة للـ complex amplitude
اللي شاركتها معكم
قبل شوي. ليش هذا مهم؟
لأننا نقدر نولّد علاقات معقدة
بين الـ qubits من حيث الأطوار
والتشابك الكمي، وبعدين من خلال القياس
نقدر نضغط هذا الكم الهائل
من الحسابات اللي صايرة جوا في
جواب مهم.
وهكذا نوصل في النهاية
للجواب. لما نحطهم جنب بعض بصرياً
تحس إن الـ classical circuit ما يقدر أبداً
يستغل الفضاء الحسابي الضخم
اللي يقدر عليه الـ quantum circuit. هذا
أحسن تصوير يعطيك الحدس
على مدى ثراء وصولنا لهذا الفضاء الكبير.
والجميل في الموضوع إنه نقدر
نصمم أنواع كثيرة من الـ circuits عشان
تؤدي وظائف مختلفة، فمثلاً
هذا circuit
مصمم لنمذجة المخاطر المالية،
وهذا مثال على circuit
يُستخدم للبحث وحل مسائل التحسين،
وهذا مثال على circuit يُستخدم لـ
محاكاة جزيء. والفكرة المهمة
إنك تقدر تصمم circuits مختلفة
لتطبيقات مختلفة.
الـ circuits اللي نصممها بتتسجل
في البرنامج وتُحفظ كبرنامج،
وعندنا نحفظها في Qiskit،
وهو مجموعة أدوات التطوير مفتوحة المصدر للحوسبة الكمية.
هذا من أكثر
أُطر البرمجة استخداماً في مجال الحوسبة الكمية.
وتقدر تتخيل إنك تبني
مكتبات من الـ circuits تتضمن في
برامج كلاسيكية تجمع بين أفضل ما في البرمجة الكلاسيكية
وأفضل ما في القوة الكمية.